[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
ouais comment ça va bon écoute ça là
j'attends eric et ramzy l'a dit moi ça
ouais ça va pas finir de bonheur là
qu'est-ce que j'ai demain ouais je suis
tranquille je peux 11h jeu soit c'est
une bonne nouvelle est à 11 heures
gilles agit maintenant je vais être
frais à la gym ouais c ou alors déjeuner
on voit les places va très bien et après
[Musique]
ça va alors si j'ai dû remettre balance
relation c'est toi qui ont différemment
garé à côté de moi 1
enfin folle à son moi enfin fola sont
bons marie astrid enfin folle à son
regard énorme revers à m'sila
ouais j'suis intervertir anzhi est
rarement bon c'est la locale de demain
si une journée cool quoi
quel bonheur écoute je me fais une joie
de vivre cette journée entièrement est
pleinement
merci merci de l'avoir ap hm devant tout
ce qu'il a tout va bien tout va bien
c'est lui
non oui bon choix bonsoir celui au
quatrième étage
s'il vous plaît merci merci
[Musique]
tu es
le français mais qu'il niait savourer
tout peu non tu reçois jo tu fais la
maîtresse de maison fondation s'ils
continuent il m'appelait faut la leçon
je vais l'appeler fogiel
[Musique]
bonjour nozipho montagneux comment
qualifier le premier c'est ça le
problème
il est un peu d'inflation qui est un peu
mollasson selon nous de semences tripod
pas jouer et j'aurais dû prendre un
stylo en main
oui il voulait mais bien ok attends je
crois que j'ai mes cigarettes dedans
ainsi comment ça va très bien et toi
ouais contents de nous recevoir 13 août
bonsoir monsieur elie semoun a chanté
salut et voilà comment monsieur prêchant
eric du bristol eric frechon stéphane et
sébastien du baron c'est un homme blanc
fait qu'est ce que tu vois moi je bois
pas d'alcool a été rasé un gîte pas vous
avez ça je le vois je suis en tournée en
ce moment ça marche
ah ouais c'est une folie était content
c'est une folie et c'est crevant coin
j'en peux plus si ça doit être terrible
tous les soirs sur ces notions
différentes l'idée date
ouais la semaine prochaine j'ai six
dates d'affilée
je vais dans l'est de la france nancy
strasbourg des villes que je connais
même pas d'elle thanh ha ouais tu
connaisses a annoncé n'arrive avec
arthur quand il est venu dans mes
missions il m'a dit deux trois villes
que je ne sais pas mais j'ai découvert
qu'elle était en suisse et en belgique
c'est pour ça qu'on est sensé pas classé
dernier en france que tu me cites la sas
et en france il faut bien les voir un
petit peu là confierait la france
profonde et c'est fatigant mais ce qu'il
faut toujours que c'est pas le spectacle
en lui-même c'est le les transports
avions trains tout ça et puis y'a pas
une mercedes blanche comme michel
delpech nord
mercedes grand échanson ah oui c'est
vrai t'as raison quand j'étais chanteur
c'est une sacrée vie un avis de tourner
mais maintenant avec les avions c'est un
peu moins drôle d'à avant les mecs isolé
ni versé de l'argent règne mouret ils
mourraient a pas un concert à devait
justement contre un platane du chantilly
de foie gras et anguilles comme un porc
mais comme si c'était un velouté envie
c'est vraiment cette fois gras au regret
c'est une vie qui dérange et le foie
gras et grands desseins mariage qui va
bien ensemble
la colombie est un peu fumé lui c'est le
plus fort à lui donner l'impression d'un
profond non mais c'est vrai ou alors
c'est un déguisement moi je suis pas du
tout que son absence fléchi la cuisine
mais aussi il était arrivé quand même si
tu vas force
il ya des gens qui jean 14 et jouissent
et jouissif pour une salle quand tu peux
plus les et si tu veux tu mouffe selon
elle à un moment pour ça que je suis si
mince cameron oui et toi j'ai entendu
une émission sur europe 1
habitant à l'antenne sa femme isabelle
morizet a très bien très bons amateurs
de très très bien j'aime bien je me suis
fait interview à bien le boss bien toi
bien comme quoi
comme quoi on n'est jamais sûr mais mme
karen cheryl une bonne joueuse mais elle
est marrante parce qu'en plus elle
je vais parler de ça sur l'ancienne
carrière tu vois et elle a fait une
croix dessus
c'était un être vivant personne oui
sinon personne comme toi un peu ta
carrière d'avant le travesti
je me souviens de ces animaux bien sûr
je pense ou là qui veut en parler c'est
l'histoire tu sais bien que rajhi toi
non non pas s'il n'y a pas deux mais je
leur dirai je le dirai enfin ceux qui
cumulent environ soit bien en fins mais
non il forma de ya pas de travail pas de
rien marcotte dakar y en ait pas de
textes sont sympathiques et endemol
c'est sympa d'ailleurs dvd là mais l'a
dit - pendant 10 minutes puisque tu sort
en dvd comme tout le monde sur vtt
arrête tes conneries non moi je suis
fier non c'est bizarre d'habitude chaque
année j'ai toujours mon dvd mes petites
annonces mon spectacle
j'ai rien ne pourra pas s'offrir un
semoun à noël à la gonfle et c'est vrai
que le ressortir le premier spectacle
que j'avais adoré d'ailleurs et des jeux
d'eau non non c'était de l'eau qui t'a
dit ça me fait des trucs
elle est riche de rebondissements il
sort des trucs non nagées sur sarthe et
le dvd du premier spectacle quoi avec
dieudo ouais mais non parce que les
images comme c'est un grand malin ouais
c'est bien beau ni fait ce qu'il veut
voilà fait ce qu'il veut tant que moi je
ne suis qu'à un nom connu un petit temps
plein dit employés et l'on se parle plus
je comprends qu est ce qu on pense tu
veux trop fort et ça c'est quoi ça c'est
un maquis avec une palourde c'est moi
les fruits de mer tu as mal avec les
noms mais je suis pas du tout je suis
juive qu'en dessous de la ceinture avec
dakar donc je suis pas de quoi tu ne
portes pas si c'est un bon ça c'est un
petit peu attendre japonaise faire ça
m'a attaqué ça
j'aime bien c'est un très fort mais là
c'est un concept tu en sois prêt classé
le nom il est génial schéma l'autre par
un peu seul et tu prends des deux si tu
donnes c'est quoi ta grande spécialité
où elle seule que les américains la sec
croient pas aux la poularde engraissée
ça c'est un bloc de dollars et il va y
arriver le ballon comme ça là il se
demande ce que c'est tu traverses la
seule avec on veut la même chose
ouais c'est une sorte de pâte et j'ai
pas comment on fait une couleur qui est
cuite dans une veste comme toi j'ai
connu des réussites kataeb poularde en
vessie ouais mais j'ai dû ne cite pas
facile pour chasser à l'intérieur et ont
filmé la tétée bien m'en aille bien où
elle était vachement bien
j'ai eu des sacrés critique je veux
c'est fou depuis le temps qu'on en
parlait de faire un film un peu serré un
autre qui va sortir sérieux s'est dit
ouais seriez aussi en fait je pensais un
truc quand j'ai vu ce film je pense que
tu peux reprendre tous les rôles
qu'aznavour a fait pas ça de gens
restent à l'affût tirait socialiste et
laura d'amérique tua lui ça non
tiré d'un roman de lanzmann parce que
jacques lanzmann avant de faire des
paroles pour dutronc il est parti en
amérique du sud travaillé dans une mine
il a vécu des choses épouvantables et
quand il est revenu il a fait un mort
elle se mêlera d'amérique pense que ça
va calmer et il m'est vraiment tous les
rôles des jeux l'adorent c'est normal on
est toujours attiré par les mecs qui te
ressemblent
ok tu pourrais perdre tous ses rôles en
frais mais là j'écris un filin en
tournée justement je me balade avec un
pote qui s'appelle philippe de chauveron
key est réalisateur effet les parasites
et on écrit on écrit un film est en
avance vachement bien
mais c'est bien enfin j'ai créé mon film
c'est elle qui ont compté en bas et
souvent je me dis mais c'est assez
bizarre stand gens qui se réunissent
pour voir un mec que tout petit tout
petit c'est génial ça gagne de l'argent
se regardent et oui voilà je suis sur ma
vraie façon aussi arthur s'y est mis moi
j'utilise très courageux non mais
sérieusement je faire que le mec tu es
une femme sublime
il a du blé il a un 4 4 et bien non il
va se faire chier ça prouve qu'ils ont
fait un beau métier du monde ça prouve
que les patrons ça prouve même prix que
la possession l'argent que ça suffisait
maintenant c'est pas mal moi je les ai
reçus je lui ai dit ouais je me dis je
trouve cela c'est que moi je assez
courageux de sa part
jolie photo nu chic ou thon mariné aux
graines de sésame
ces belles traditions pardon s'il vous
plaît excusé tout
oui bonsoir oui on voulait manger
gratuit il réclame 10 à boire et
j'écoutais au quatrième étage s'il vous
plaît je vois ce n'est pas la même
voiture dès son salut et je vous êtes en
1h10 sondagière disons crois pas que des
traboules 1 au quatrième merci l'artiste
la terre
[Musique]
monsieur ardisson vous où il faut la
santé à l'interphone oui bon d'accord je
mange arrive
alors oui alors
alors
mais personne
avec jean-pierre décidé de monter
wen
sabran
[Musique]
benoit xi à bach hamba voilà j'aurai
connaissant rien dit je crois qu'on se
dise qu'on est de dire c'est pas la wii
allait annoncer finir super salut mais
bon c'était bien de se voir aussi avec
toi l'avait barbares forum ce mardi soir
c'est donc par la cuisine avec fureur
c'est le voir huawei
c'est vrai mais c'est de l'herbe s'est
fait pousser de l'herbe le maire voulait
me confier votre manteau qui chassent
monde dont je pète un câble je vous le
donnerai tout à l'heure monsieur quand
on est un peu sous les bras tu fais deux
heures j'ai commandé une caïpirinha
exceptions pas venu cette chaussure
dessin autour de toi messieurs je veux
c'est qu'on n'a pas touché
c'est sébastien du baron qui fait de ce
al-ahmad je vais prendre un verre du lma
[Applaudissements]
j'ai ramené l'argent on dit j'ai tout
vendu et voilà y'a tout vu que même ici
terrain des bandes trois bidons
d'essence et il ya deux piètres nitot
qui sont partis il valait sur l'internet
et leur dire larsen et j'arrête et
consommer et en génère d'un bouchon pour
la mère des 40 euros et me disais que
gagner énormément d'argent ce qui fait
la taille n'est pas ce que font moins
d'heures au fait des roches point qu'on
le dise qu il se balade hors satan
attends attends balle pas non plus je
veux dire non mais c'est vrai que
excusez moi j'ai un message à ses
dessins c'est bon pour m
c'est parti je suis content d'être là
moi et c'est le vôtre ouais tu fais bien
ici tu es bien reçu ça va aller de mieux
en mieux
l'argent
[Musique]
de plus marc et j'ai beaucoup j'en ai
besoin message eric ne rend pas l'argent
aubay 4 heures du matin comme il sait
rien ça peut être ok je viens de mètres
carrés dont 60 mais pas beaucoup
tu mérite qu'on brûle ta voiture alors
prends le menu voilà c'est indécent
maintenant il s'est notamment chez vas-y
appuyez sur entrée là je suis là mais
moi voilà c'est la honte réclamé en
agence vous samedi entre le sont
surcotés
regarde s'il ne bouge pas cette vaste
retour mais parce que sans regarder les
seuls regarde rien rien
ça change puis je donne pas mon argent
par exemple assez fou c'est dans
[Applaudissements]
c'est nous allons là bien au kadima est
juste à côté pour un problème 2 à 1
c'était au new york j'arrive pas à moi
je n'arrive pas je ne peux pas te vois
tu aimes pas je n'aime pas ce spectacle
non mais j'arrive pas à me regarder un
incrément aussi pourquoi je me dégoûte
la ferme les yeux fermés yeux regarde je
veux voir l' âge adore ça sonore et
c'est un vrai annoncé bien j'ai trouvé
cette série de comics qui rentre au
costa rica sont saisies c'est quoi le
maximum
non mais ça j'adore ça c'est mon rêve
entre
allez on va chercher le sketch the hero
serra n'est pas venu à moi aussi j'adore
les spectacles pas plus tard que hier
soir je suis allé voir un spectacle de
chevaux franchement y avait un quart
d'heure de trop il trouvait qu'il rigole
souvent les gens me demandaient des
superstitieux je crois pas l'être non
mais quand je vois un grand canard blanc
descendre la rivière
je suis sûr c'est un signe que cana
blanc c'était un vieux vous êtes super
audience toutes les terres en amazonie
auditoire avec l'équivalent de deux
terrains de big bang
rires
coûteux
helix abba eban à grenoble
c'est pas grave continue enchaîne en
challenge et barry sky
il bouge ta baguette baroin
bon moi j'ai du mal
j'allais aux toilettes je vais juste aux
toilettes s'il vous plaît comme ça ce
sera réglé
à part dire ce qu'on pense
qu'est ce que tu fous et ce mec c'est
quoi ce genre de questions en voyant ça
voilà pour ce jour très dur de soi mais
bien le spectacle
après vous allez trouver des gags après
ajustement oui c'est pas la c1 cela
c'est insupportable à l'eau azouz begag
thierry ardisson bonsoir non je bouffais
je vais dire la vérité je bouffe avec
deux potes trois potes
eric et ramzy elie semoun et on voulait
appeler pour te pour te supporter ouais
je te passe ramzy un ouais je sais je te
passera me dire bonsoir à 12
et toi et vous comment ça va
je suis très content de vous avoir au
téléphone et on voulait vous soutenir
parce qu'on vous avez en vous a vu à la
télé on vous a entendu et pour vous
c'est vrai au lavage et bas nous c'est
pour vous dire à tous qu'on était avec
vous de tout coeur et que ont supporté
tout ce que vous disiez la sueur sur le
sur ce qu'on sait qu'on a est derrière
vous ouais
mais heureusement que vous l'avez ouvert
heureusement que vous l'avez ouvert
heureusement je vous embrasse à josé
puis je dois vous rappeler pour un autre
truc qu'on est ensemble ouais je le
passeport ouais c'est vrai c'est marrant
parce que j'ai eu un message cet après
midi justement de oued énergie qui nous
demandait de faire des messages pourra
pour apaiser les les jeunes pour calmer
les jeunes nous on n'est pas présent en
banlieue évidemment mais c'est étrange
de nous le demander à nous alors que
marca j'imagine la faillite de l'état
[Musique]
oui bonsoir oui bonsoir c'est étrange et
94 au quatrième étage s'il vous plaît
merci messieurs
il est
[Musique]
dans ma tête
plus de pub est quand même en on ne
porte ici si j'étais connu
[Musique]
face au dollar
mes yeux
[Musique]
3 l bonsoir ce soir
départ à 12 ans c est vous passez par
l'écurie d'accord
[Musique]
les choses
fra batum et diot la pêche toit du tour
une soirée banlieusards ces soirées la
cité va craquer ou quoi c'est pas
toujours que des intelligents qui
jettent heures non mais c'est que la
moitié sont mineurs
c'est incroyable c'est le désarroi et la
misère il touche toutes les catégories a
raconté une histoire est reçue cjce
heures de banlieue c'est qu'en fait le
mec qui fait des études qui bac + 3 bla
bac + 4 qui trouvent pas de boulot parce
qu'il s'appelle mohamed ou autre chose
babel et son petit frère qu'à 14 ans qui
dit regarde ce qu'ont ils à l'école je
perds 23 ans
ça c'est la patte de l'eau moi je
préfère vendre du shit et machines
marcourt donc si tu veux au fait même
pas ça excuse moi de teint terreux
mais même pas ça c'est même pas ça le
discours c'est juste je vois moi je
un exemple tout concret ma belle soeur
qui avait déjà de droits qui ne trouvent
pas de travail qu'à un nom cramer qui
est brillante vraiment est super déçu
elle appelle bout nous l'avons joue de
la guitare a bola bambou laqué
sacro-saint vrai que c'est un beau
toujours est il que l a fait donc ses
études tous les gens qui sont qui ont
fait le de hackett qui était dans la
même promo quelle ils sont tous
ils ont tous un travail maintenant
qu'elle elle galère et que ses petites
soeurs elle voit ça et elles vendent pas
de la drogue mais elles sont juste des
raisons pour brûler des voitures
effectivement mais en même temps quand à
une crise une crise de tétanie les mets
qui brûlent leur voiture il brûle pas
les voitures de il y avait peut-être
trois voitures qui ont brûlé à paris
mais les bruits brûlent les voitures qui
sont en banlieue donc c'est le mec qui
se griffent le visage quoi elles étaient
pas plus belle des cités avec les
voitures en bon état pas d'accord je
crois pas qu'il faille déjà qu'il faille
leur dire ça pour commencer
et en plus je crois que c'est vrai que
c'est difficile c'est super difficile
les chemins je peux pas dire le
contraire mais c'est pas impossible de
venir de là aussi je veux dire si les
révolutions et lierse et si un
changement ça doit venir aussi d'ici il
faut s'armer il faut s'armer armes et
son esprit et pour ça il ya rien de
mieux que le cube que les études tu veux
c'est avec vendre du shit pour
rentabiliser c'est un problème mais je
pense qu'il faut quand même avoir
munitions
on te fait faire des études jusqu'à 25
ans et si t'as pas de boulot parce que
tu t'appelles mohamed à quoi ça sert je
suis super d'accord avec ce discours là
et je suis pas pour un discours négatifs
mais je pense que grâce à ce but gag
n'est-il pas vraiment l'exemple type du
mec qui a fait des études qui est
brillant qu'il ya des compétences qui
doit faire deux fois plus qu'un français
qui s'appelle jean-françois mignard et
qui au bout du compte finalement était
un alibi et qui on lui met un mur devant
le nez donc clairement il ya un il ya un
problème
et quand je vois le président getti qui
appelle les musulmans de france à se
calmer avec le d'un côté les français
pure souche qui des bulles qui défilent
en chantant la marseillaise c'est chaud
quoi il ya l'agetur et sérieuse il
chante pas vraiment là c'est la preuve
que tout ce qui se passe c'est une
mauvaise
ils peuvent pas faire autrement que
d'utiliser le langage de la violence
mais le problème c'est que résultats
benjamins qui adorent aller en garde à
vue et mettre la capuche soit surtout il
a personne tu vas rester là c'est pas un
idéal de vie pour personnes faut arrêter
de croire ça tout le monde tout le monde
envie d'avoir une vie normale
toulouse a envie de quitter sa voix tout
le monde veut travailler avoir des
enfants ils venaient tous la preuve on a
eu la chance aussi une chance c'est tout
on a passé sur ce malheureux que
justement c'est alors à oui non mais
attendez la sédation mais en train de
dîner là c'est sébastien chine ou du
syndicat général de la police
je vais vous passez un ami il appelle
bien le mec du syndicat général de la
police comment il s'appelle il veut
faire l'émission a offert tout le monde
ressort monsieur série car eric et ramzy
ils représentent les deux eric et ramzy
erikel de eric et ramzy de ramzi les
deux comiques super marrant et alors que
c'est maroc la police appelle au moment
où dîner ensemble qu'est ce qu'on a fait
ouais les tutoyant nous j'ai toujours
tutoyer la police a plutôt toujours été
l' inverse en fait
immo toujours tutoyer j'en doute il ya
des flics super cool je les ai pas vus
mais on a pu m'en a parlé
à chaque fois la police marc parent télé
d'accord mais sincèrement il faut faut
dialoguer il faut arrêter de faut
arrêter de l'étape est là parce que je
crois que il ya vraiment un mal être un
malaise il ya vraiment quelque chose et
je pense pas qu'on fasse ça pour rien je
croyais et je crois par les jeux vous
leur passe tout de suite
et s'il vous plaît ranger votons pas au
revoir tient bon c'est terminé je
rappelle demain matin merci à lui
[Musique]
comment
on
il
oui bon choix les artistes
m
vous
ain azel feront soir on voit passer par
action
enfin
m
ce bigarrée g
mais là si on n'y vais pas sait on est
juste vraiment fou louret revoilà mais
gagne le psg des fois on est bien là
cette année on est bel et bien cette
année on est là on fait un bon début de
championnat
moi je dit le parisien pour savoir le
psg et là ils ont marqué le psg marque
le pas 0-0 à monaco mais tu étais à
monaco avant toi non ouais ya deux
saisons et alors ça va parce que c'était
bien j'en avais marre de pas payer
d'impôts non mais on paie les impôts
quand même
ah bon ouais les français et ouais si
que les étrangers quand il habite à
monaco ils paient pas d'impôts j'ai
aucun intérêt mais voilà c'est pour ça
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui pensent
que le fait d'habiter à monaco joue à
monaco ça nous sommes par exemple de
payer d'impôts non pas du tout non non
excusez moi je suis moi edwards qu'est
ce qu'un grand edouard qu un très très
grand joueur pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
respect étaient en file indienne
kaupthing avec monaco et quand il est
venu à paris la pad est perdu il a rien
perdu
l'équipe et c'est pas bête des
perroquets janek tenterait pas de que
d'entendre ça monsieur je ne serai
content du travail de monsieur g bat-il
de ge a rien à dîner pour un combat sur
temps habité que vous monsieur que je
combien de fois je vous ai vu aucun
regret on va saisir va discuter dehors
j'ai des bagnoles j'ai des bidons
d'essence
on va se marrer c'est vrai que la halle
aux toiles chez lui michaël youn qui
revenait d'une présentation de la jda
toi il était chaud comme la braise chaud
bouillant qu'est ce que s'est passé on a
fait la présentation de la nouvelle
collection stringfellow donc et avait
way avait emma daumas que l'attaqué
n'était pas là c'est un pote
stringfellow ça vous a vu très petit 12
mai
conséquence on n'a jamais loupé notre
vie mais c'est juste super frustrant
fait de ce transfert
mes joueuses ont marqué quand même après
mon abandon des années qu'il est
maintenant tu peux pas donner aux
plaisirs vous serez jamais nous piquent
il va bien
labrie bronze au fur et à mesure
l'antique bah ouais ouais tu fais des uv
ben je pense pas qu'ils aient place
devait jouer au tennis et le tennis à
bronze c'est une énorme nouvelle pièce
la wii mais il n'a pas dit de lui une
pièce avec marilou berry au théâtre des
royals il s'appelle top cops et on était
à chambéry a pas longtemps ses rapports
avec mario mairie oui bonsoir
rim'k du 113 au quatrième étage
s'il vous plaît merci la ville de sedan
ouais je change de nom ils reprennent
l'entraînement dans ce jeu s'appelle
james qui deviendra cautionner ça parce
que lui c'est un vrai comique non
[Musique]
oh
monsieur bonsoir toi
ap
wen confiez votre bojan communauté
oh
leur viande au corps ramenés des fleurs
dont méritent examen est connecté à dire
que je vais du preneur transporte dans
les pays à des noirs pour tous ces gens
libérés de la peur qui les pentes qui
aime la vie mais celle ci leur a fait un
blessé mortels
quelques rimes que tu peux comparer aux
larmes du soleil un jour était en cure à
des hommes et une femme qui sait
conclure cette belle télé commun
tous les fans présents même dans la
tourmente chacun regret jean domicile
guerre des tranchées ta couleur de peau
de faire de toi un étranger tu trouves
ça normal quand je me sens chez moi
n'importe où citoyen du monde avec peu
de moyens mais l'iran mois au fond de
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre quand je
vois ces mômes à lever du mal nourris
victimes de maltraitance mitri mon cadre
de vie rongé par le trafic
comme les aides humanitaires
pour l'afrique au fure glaçons dit
suffit pas de se lever du bon pied
traverse les flammes courageux et brave
comme un pompier
s'il a fait mauvais temps passé ce monde
juste un jour
une trêve une pause pour que l'on sache
après contours sait trop encore ce que
signifie l'amour j'ai bien peur de nous
nous le montre avec à ton avis et
équivalents ce qui se passe ici à ce
qu'il a eu à l'époque aouate
moi j'ai la façon c'est exactement la
même chose parce que les mecs ça se fête
est la même qu avec 158 raison tu es
doigt les mecs se tire une eau à compton
là les mecs sont tirés une balle dans le
pied
ils ont cramé leur propre commerce et
c'est exactement la même chose qui se
reproduit ici c'est juste une espèce de
de réactions allergiques quoi qu'ils
peuvent pas contrôler c'est clairement
de la révolution française voulait pas
de la révolution russe mais qu'ils aient
des brûlés les trucs des riches
à la différence que cette révolution là
elle est faite par des gamins de 14 ans
et c'est une énorme différence parce que
il n'y a aucune raison il ya aucun
discours derrière il ya une espèce de
rage et de gamins qui tape son père et
qui est qui et qui donne des coups de
poing dans le ventre
il n'y a pas de raisonnement il n'y a
pas de calcul je les choses c'est que
dans les cités on a coupé le dialogue
serre que les seuls contacts qu'ils
avaient avec l'état avec la loi c'était
la police inciter la mairie c'était les
associations de jeunes tous ces budgets
ont été coupées les mecs ne partent plus
en vacances
les mecs ne ne font plus rien ils
galèrent dans leur rôle pour l'heure
interdite depuis les lois sarkozy
d'aller dans les halls donc leur propre
petit foyer social leur petite vie
culturelle
on leur interdit donc les mecs n'ont
plus de contacts que j'avais avec l'état
que par la répression
donc la seule réaction à sa quant à 14
ans et que ton raisonnement n'est pas
encore complètement terminé fodé et n ya
pas une culture derrière il n'y a pas
juste 30 ans de d'expérience derrière et
bien à 14 ans battu brûle les bagnoles
il peut y avoir des îlotiers il peut y
avoir des gens une espèce de rapport de
proximité avec la police et les jeunes
quoi ce qui n'existe plus puisque les
flics sont mais la police de proximité
en bleu ça c'était bien ça franchement
inexistante
j'ai pas vu je voulais prendre des buts
comme ça c'est pas à proximité
sauf pas ce qui se passe vraiment
moi-même je t'ai laissé un pv de 35 ans
meli on sent que quand on quand on se
voit il a envie de se marrer avec des
gens tout ça ne s'est pas tu as un peu
triste un peu triste je les vois quand
j'ai fait le film avec eux là des dalton
kg par suit le dvd performant mais à mon
avis ils m'ont rappelé l'époque où
j'étais avec dieu d'eau et où on était
pire que est plus drôle que ça parce que
nous on était dans le social nous on
était contents mais j'en étais content
non mais c'est vrai qu'à deux c'est plus
drôle c'est plus drôle
j'attends plat ça manque un peu quand je
les vois ça m'énerve je les aime quand
même est-ce que tu as pensé à trouver un
ou deux partenaires
je pensais alors personne
bonjour mesdames messieurs ça me fait
défaut
nous ne sommes pas déçus al assad je
sais pas si vous avez vu mais lui laisse
est différent nous geismeier france est
meilleure que c'est bon signe jamais de
ta vie tu viens dans mon assiette de la
purée travail la france s'est compliqué
entre les mecs qui pensent qu'elle sera
là nous les atouts on est super sympa en
plus de tous nous ouais mais c'est ça
qui les couilles avec leur allah le
cachet assez bien donc ça tu écriras
l'assassinât lâche qu'est ce que c'est
ça c'est du carré d'agneau rôti de ça
c'est quoi alors ça c'est un appel une
pomme de terre champ vallon comprendre
l'épaule d'agneau que l'on confie et ont
fait acquis avant soir qui la voient là
poursuit à la pomme de terre sont super
bons américains
merci beaucoup je m attendais rien du
tout moi cette année aux jeunes agneaux
si hockey y avait une cuisson qu'il
fallait encore un petit peu mieux son
corps
moi ce que je trouve bizarre chez vous
les cathos c'est quand vous frappe à
gauche vous tendez la droite
j'ai jamais compris comment dans ce
clanwar contre une fois tu te retournes
et cela complique je n'ai jamais tourné
le dos à un catholique
le centre d'excellence mais le jeu du
sel à compenser
série si je peux me permettre je pensais
que je lui posais la question
subrepticement ton jardinier comme ça tu
sais il a il a eu des critiques
dithyrambiques pour son film polisse son
service amazon prime sérieux et je
demandais c'était quoi le plus qui fend
est ce que c'était de faire des films
populaires qui marche mais qui se font
défoncer ou bien des films super parce
que j'avais répondu d'ailleurs avait dit
tu te faire vers les fonds qui font des
entrées comme tu en avais pas fait je me
suis dis que j'ai eu des moments comme
ça fait assez ridicule
c'était pas mal moi je trouve ça me dit
que tu l'as vu ouais bah oui je même si
bien pas chez moi je le ressentais des
vachers prochaine j'étais si fogiel mois
pour sa part on a le même nom mais pas
pour le film
quant à elle chez fogiel je veux tu fais
ce que tu veux mais tu discutes dieu par
des noms mais j'ai fait une course se
risqua attention tirèrent descend ça va
pas et sympathique mais ça peut vite
pour le chocolat n'est pas d'accord sur
tout mais c'était vous hisse à tous
je me demandais où j'allais rct bon ca
marche et ça marche mieux aller chez
fogel
j'ai été chez fogiel mais cette espèce
de salon il ya longtemps non dans le
film et 4 6 1 non je te jure que non
ah non au delà des infos que gt gt avec
jean paul rouve jeux à pékin se faisait
chiper un oui catherine elie semoun
quand il a fait son film nous allons
enfin à aux abois il est bien les
chevaux j aime quand même non catherine
barma temps catherine mois a nommé
katherine - total a ouai bon donc tu dis
qu'il a fait fogiel tu es d'accord
annoncé faute united a fait fogiel fou
mais c'est pas moi je m'oblige pas à
tanger catherine barma voilà catherine a
dit catherine adx quel temps voulu car
il c'est faux j'ai pas fait fogiel
s'ériger total 1 viennent tous les
conneries dans nos temps catherine barma
le sait que j'appelle fogiel attaquant
numéro parce que je vais vomir c'est toi
la cuma par gabe merde c'est la liste à
gauche maintenant là alors pour y aller
avec des mecs comme ça toute la journée
non non ils sont pas comme ça toute la
journée les partis on peut dire la
vérité sur lui ouais dites-le c'est un
vrai coup
son film est allé chez fogiel donc cette
nouvelle animatrice du bien c'est de la
merde je fais ni de cette crèche voulait
mettre des petites [ __ ] dawn est
tous derrière paris 2012 n'empêche pas
légion oui alors à passer 10 boss
bâtiment sans les gars nous depuis notre
retour de ce voyage spatial on a
vraiment au courant de tout juste
puisque ben en fait je leur dis du coma
avant-hier
qu'est ce que vous pensez sérieusement
d'elie semoun c'est pas le moment de
dire jean lapeyre sa salle par des
asexuels il est ressorti trois groupes
depp arrive bientôt des toits les ans on
n'y avait que du bien de toi silence on
va parler télévision résidence était
champion de soi en toi tu quittes jeudi
l'étude nrj 12 aux tirs et je le quitte
de minutie sandra pourquoi parce que
deux minutes de prison 20 pour y avait
une vanne de merde y'a plus lourdes et
se donner
j'ai lu un truc au canada tu l'avais vu
que tu avais fait des barbus au canada
on a fait on a fait un petit sketch
ensemble rigolo ça soit à la on a fait
un truc où moi je disais que je disais
toute façon il est hors de question
qu'on me voit avec toi là moi je suis on
est en duplex en fait je suis à paris
tout cas ce que cela n'est pas de mon
ressort juste voilà on a fait un sketch
de pseudo réconciliation bidon ou le
disait qu'il n'était pas là que c'était
virtuel etc ne fallait pas qu'on voit
avec lui voilà c'était rigolo on s'est
téléphoné après et alors est ce qu ils
s'inquiètent incroyable c'est que à
l'époque où jean jacques rousseau était
vivement c'est de là que vient
l'expression de type à mais pourquoi on
dit petit peu parce que les gens à
l'époque du moyen âge parler à marcher à
petits pas
non mais voilà et après après j'ai eu au
téléphone tout le voir à revoir je suis
allé voir je te vois pas rater les
femmes et les gens pensaient que si tu
es vraiment réconcilier et et on s'est
dit que non non non c'est pas
réconcilier la batterie conçue non c'est
impossible pas c'est impossible à jouer
trop chaud nous et la panique que vous
répondez vite
t'imagines si vous réconcilie sont au
chômage dans la merde
vous n'avez déjà une belle place ici
mais on vous soutient dans votre
séparation comme tu viens c'est très
concret je lui en veux ouais je suis pas
le seul à lui en vouloir
quoi c'est un peu choquant même ce qu'il
a fait je sais pas lui était pas faite
au lieu de défendre les blacks il a mis
deux communautés l'une contre l'autre
brest n'a pas pris de chocolat jusqu'à
des trucs à mon avis et de la noisette
de à tapper horst tappert mérite d'avoir
un jeune de quick
elle n'empêche si tu vas aux concurrents
que de mac do et il offre dans les happy
meal des petites broches c'est un
diadème de quick josiane de quick
minutes de prison je suis là
[Musique]
oui bon choix
mais bon soir c'est le souffle grand
corps malade du 4e étage vers celle de
san marco à doha marco m'appelle marco
que certaines places en attaque où il a
battu peu la tradition il faut l'assumer
simon soit bien longtemps vous connais
pas ce comédien a touché
[Musique]
pourtant même dans les beaux quartiers
c
ma
[Musique]
deux grands pots et grands alors je
voudrais faire un slam pour une grande
dame que je connais depuis tout petit je
voudrais un slam pour celle qui voit ma
vieille cannes du lundi au samedi
je devais faire un slam pour une vieille
femme dans laquelle j'ai grandi je
voudrais faire un slam pour cette
banlieue nord paname qu'on appelle saint
denis si tu aime voyager prendre à moi
et vos marchés en une heure tu traverses
sera à alger et angers tu verras d hugo
et des roms et puis je t'emmènerai à
lisbonne et à de panyu délier de karachi
vu s'ériger réviser ma géographie
deviendrait bouffer du mafé à bamako et
à yamoussoukro où si tu préfères on ira
juste derrière moi j'ai une crêpe de 500
quimper où c'est un petit air du
finistère et repassant par tizi ouzou où
finira aux antilles dans les grosses
renois qui font aussi leur accord ou
café là ma fille au marché de saint
denis il faut que tu sois zik fils et
aime pas être bousculé tu devra rester
zen mais surtout prendra des accents
plein les tympans et des odeurs plein
zen si tu veut bouffer pour trois fois
rien je connais bien tous les petits
coups un peu poisseux on y retrouvera
tous les vauriens toute la jet set des
aristocraties le soir il ya pas grand
chose à faire il n'y a pas grand chose
d'ouvert
à part le cinéma du stade où les mecs
viennent en bande bienvenue acquérir
allende
ceux qui sont là rêvent de dire un jour
je pèse et connaissent le kool shen
selon bruno lopes c'est pas une ville
toute rose mais c'est une ville vivante
il se passe toujours quelque chose pour
moi électif hante saint denis ville sans
égal salima capitale saint denis ville
peu banale ou à carrefour tu peut même
acheter de la choucroute la halle là bas
on est fier des dionysiens j'espère que
tu es convaincu et celui qui me traitent
de parisiens je leur fonce ma béquille
donc non autorisées je voudrais faire un
slam pour une grande dame que je connais
depuis tout petit je me fais un slam
pour celle qui voit ma vieille cannes du
lundi au samedi
je voudrais fait un slam pour une
vieille femme dans laquelle j'ai grandi
je voudrais faire un slam pour cette
banlieue nord de paname qu'on appelle
saint denis
j'ai rencontré la poésie elle avait un
air bien prétentieux elle prétendait qu
avec les mots on pouvait traverser les
cieux je le dis je t'ai déjà croisés et
franchement tu vaut pas le coup
on m'a parlé de toi à l'école et avait
l'air vraiment relou mais la poésie a
insisté et m'a rattrapé sous d'autres
formes
j'ai compris qu'elle était cool et qu'on
pouvait bravé ces normes je vais
demander tu pense qu'on peut vivre
ensemble je crois que je suis accro
elle m'a dit inquiète le monde
appartient à ceux qui rêvent trop vite
maintenait thiel café de france juste en
bas de page il est tenu par des rebeus
je te jure ça s'invente pas et des meufs
bien coiffé qui viennent prendre un café
des petits coupés serein qui viennent
boire un coup avant d'en tirer un il ya
des gentils poivrot qui viennent oublier
leurs galères dans la bière surtout le
printemps surtout l'été surtout le town
surnuméraires aujourd hui m même des
tables en terrasse vue de ma fenêtre ya
plein de monde au soleil c'est la classe
et comme je vois tout de ma plante comme
un keuf mes potes m'appelle avant de
venir pour savoir s'il ya de la meuf une
manette suite je vois le plus souvent
c'est du dos il est gentil mais quand tu
le crois c'est pas forcément un cadeau
si tu ne supportes pendant une heure je
te jure t costaud c'est le mec qu'on
appelle la cerise sur le gâteau une ma
fenêtre c'est pas de la télé réalité ni
un site comme d'hab et production je
vois pas mal de gens qui triment et voit
la vie comme une sanction
et même si face à la galère ils
préfèrent se taire ils mettent pas de
genou à terre et le poing en l'air et
reste fier surtout le printemps surtout
l'été surtout le town surtout l'hiver
parce que oui vu de ma fenêtre je vois
pas mal d'espoirs quand je vois un petit
blond jouer au foot avec le petit noir
quand je vois des gens qui se bougent
quand je vois des gens qui se mettent
des coups de pied au cul pour sortir de
la zone rouge
et pour que la vie vaille le coup d'être
vécue quand je vois ces deux hommes qui
boivent un coup ensemble en riant alors
qu'ils sont soit disant différent parce
que lundi shalom et le 10 à l'âme mais
[ __ ] et serre la main c'est sa lame de
mon slam je prends ça comme un bon signe
c'est peut-être un espoir infime mais je
te jure que je l' ai vu c'est pas pour
la rime
moi c'est vrai qu'une ma fenêtre je vois
aussi la galère la misère les
suicidaires et les retours au pays un
charter mais je suis un [ __ ] de rêveur
un grand optimiste c'est une philosophie
qui me suis alors je me dis que ça peut
s'arranger
j'espère donc je suis fils ma fenêtre
avec des bâtiments si je te disais que
jon la verdure tu ce règlement et puis
pour voir un bout de ciel faut se
pencher franchement mais vas-y vient
chez moi on regardera par la fenêtre
tu comprendras pourquoi je rigole
pourquoi je crains pourquoi je rêve
pourquoi j'espère surtout le printemps
surtout l'été surtout le town surtout
l'hiver
où j'ai le sentiment qu'elle suppose le
sang qui push de santé pour toi et ta
belle bouche y avait des signes ça me
troue
or de nos jours de trouver un homme qui
ne trompent pas
une simple étant un oeuf
père de m
moi qui suis si dur d'habitude j'en ai
perdu mon amertume des gestes non
cet état
quelque chose de la sorte
sans guère notre histoire nos mots nos
malheurs la nôtre à la lueur de l'homme
mais c'était un peu avant l'heure
jeunesse en clair que bouger les gens
qui bougent des sorties de toit et on
peut
les quatre hommes et jean les pères de
la voix
la légèreté n'était pas très beau à voir
j'affirme etc ont été faits pour un
conte de fées sans fin
détruire des enfants je te parlais
fidélité mariage
mais jetez pas des masques et des
démarrages ans ils voulaient tous
d'importants intérêts quitte à faire
packard
l'embêtant avec lui tu m'as bbc
négus de faty n'étais pas une fille
facile tu m'as offert une mauvaise chute
aujourd'hui n'aurait acquis la certitude
tout n'est qu'une vraie ont trois fois
passé 1
mais c'est l'enfer qui vous tend
c'est fait
[Musique]
m enfin et
certains à main
[Musique]
c'est un fait
me
non
[Musique]
fabien va bien là ce serait bien avant
classé 11e à débloquer grâce à ce succès
on va sucer ce sens qu'ils déploient est
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu